LEON ZHAO: OK, so
Michael, we just
talked about the
material design.
So what are some of the
[? best ?] [? directives ?]
that you have seen--
like, real cases--
implementing material design?
How do you work with developers
on implementing that,
and what are some of the
difficulties and challenges
in the process?
MICHAEL YEUNG:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
--material design--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--YouTube--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] --YouTube--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--Google Maps--
tangible servers--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--a floating action button--
--navigation--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--Google--
--developer--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--material design--
--Lollipop--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--material design--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] --Lollipop
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] --Kit
Kat [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] --Ice
Cream Sandwich--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[? app compat ?] library--
androiddeveloper.blogspot.com
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--blogger--
--Android developer--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--material--
--code-- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--compatibility--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
LEON ZHAO: Koh, do
you have any example
to add as we talk upstage
So YouTube would be-- YouTube
and [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--example.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--real case of some material
design that you can google--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
KOH KIM: There's a couple.
I mean, all the
Google Apps are very
good examples of
material design-- like,
the simplification, really
focus on bright colors, a lot
of the scrolling mechanics.
There's a couple of other
third-party applications
that are pretty
good examples too.
AirBnB has very
good browsing when
you go check out a lot of the
photos, a lot of the listings
and the places.
I think Uber recently
redesigned their app too.
A lot of the bigger
apps have started
redesigning a lot of their
apps to kind of create
that more friendly
interface and also
the simplification of
being able to scroll,
really focus on the elements,
and a lot of bright colors.
And I think the
users are definitely
engaging a lot more
within those applications.
KH MIN: So do you have
any specific [INAUDIBLE]
in Japan and Korea, as well?
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: In
Japan market, they are--
so recently the material
design is getting popular among
the application developers
and and the money for it,
[? which ?] is managing the
individual people's money
in and out, that application
corresponded for the material
design last week, and they
doing the [? bill ?] roll.
They're increasing the KPI stuff
with their material design.
That's trending in Japan.
And that would be the
[? exist ?] [? the ?]
[? only ?] in Japan market.
Then probably everyone
in Japan's market
will follow those
trends and momentum
of the material design.
KH MIN: And in Korea,
most of the inquiries
on material design are coming
from newspaper and magazine
applications.
So the one example is the
[? bingo, ?] for example.
They are very popular
magazine applications.
And now they adopted some
animations or the UX design
of material design.
So that is one example, but
still they are working on it.
So I cannot say there
are many examples yet.
But I'm pretty sure that
it'll be very popular.
LEON ZHAO: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--Google Play--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--material design--
--phone-- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--tablets--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
So the question is if
you want to get featured
on Google Play for apps,
is it a prerequisite
to have material
design and also design
for both phone and tablet.
So it's more maybe for the
[INAUDIBLE] Also Michael,
I think you can also
answer that as well.
MICHAEL YEUNG:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
--material design--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--feedback--
--feature-- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--material design--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] --material
design-- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
KOH KIM: Start from over
there, and then come back.
Is material design
required [INAUDIBLE]
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
Material design
is not mandatory for
featuring in Japan.
KH MIN: What about
design for apps--
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: The
guideline for a more like co-op
guideline is almost
mandatory and also
the [? back order ?] and stuff.
And they're using the
Android the UI/UX.
That's the important things
for, as a minimum, [INAUDIBLE]
KH MIN: I think
material design is--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
The Google suggestion is to
the [? interact ?] [? with ?]
developers.
I can give you one example.
There's one camera
application, and then I
think their UX is really
good, really cool.
But-- this is a
[? severe ?] case--
I gave a present to my father.
And then he started to
use that application,
but somehow there's phone call
coming when he used the camera.
But he knew that when he
pressed the volume button
that it actually muted the rings
before he got the phone call.
But that camera
application is actually
using that volume
key for zooming.
So there's a phone call, but
my father tried to mute it,
but it's still zooming.
So my father's feedback is, oh,
this is very difficult for me.
So that means that
even though you
are spending a lot of resources
to develop your applications
to users, they might
think that, oh, it's
kind of difficult
for me, unless you
are having design or consistent
way of using the Android
applications.
So that's why I'm saying thing
that the material design is
kind of a suggestion, and then
also a correct guideline is
talking about navigations
or back buttons
to make a consistent user
experience to every application
featured by Google Play.
KOH KIM: Yeah, it's
definitely not a requirement.
I think what you want to think
about is your user experience.
And so what you
want your users--
I mean, for them to be able to
understand how do you navigate
within your
application, how do you
do specific actions, especially
within your applications,
and also if they have
sharing capabilities how
they share that, you want to
make sure that's very obvious.
I think the two things that
you really want to take note
is that the UI and
UX navigations can
be very different between
a phone and a tablet,
especially within application.
Time and time again I see a
lot of menu navigation bars
not really fitting
to a tablet form
factor versus a mobile device,
or at least a smartphone.
In a smartphone you actually
have calling capabilities,
right?
Whereas a tablet doesn't
have calling capabilities.
But then when you think about
portrait versus landscape mode
in a tablet,
everyone kind of uses
a tablet in landscape mode,
predominately-- sometimes
portrait-- whereas in
a phone, it's portrait.
So you always want
to think about
at what are the use cases
that your users will
be using your applications.
And then how are
they going to differ
between a smartphone device
and also a tablet device.
LEON ZHAO: Thank you.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--material design--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] --Android
design guidelines--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--apps-- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--featured on Google Play--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--Dana-- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
policy [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
So it's about keyword spam.
DANA YANG: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--keyword spam--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--description--
LEON ZHAO: OK,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Beta testing and staged
rollout is a unique feature
offered by Google Play.
So what are some best
practices by a developer
that you observe in
your specific market
that you can share
with the audience here.
KOH KIM: So a lot of our app
developers do use beta testing
and staged rollouts, given the
sheer number of Android devices
out there.
And it's a good way
to kind of actually
test out which functions
and features and UX and UI
is actually going to work with
a lot of those specific users.
Facebook actually
uses this a lot.
They actually make
very extensive use
of staged rollouts
to test stability
within their application,
also testing out
new features, new layouts.
And then they do this
very extensively.
They even have this
another group of users
that they use that does--
I think it's closed alpha
testing-- for a very
different application.
But what's great with
Google is that there's
no really certification
process or an official QA
you need to publish
your application.
As long as you publish
an application that
is very safe for
all users and it
passes all the standard checks,
you're going to see the build,
and you're going to see
it live within hours.
And you can update
as many times as you
want without having to
wait anyone to say, hey,
this is now approved.
And so that's the power of
being able to rapidly iterate
your product according to
what your users' feedback is,
because devices are going
to be very different.
People are going to have
a different network,
mobile broadband
infrastructures,
all around the world.
And especially if you want
to create a product that
can hit global scale
distribution, making
very extensive use
of this feature
is going to be to
your advantage.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
For launching
the next major version
up in this digital world
is pretty common in
Japan market too.
It's pretty safe to roll
out the next version
of the application.
Then they're checking-- like 10
persons and then 15 persons--
checking the bugs.
And they fix the bugs,
and then go 100 persons
usually in like two weeks.
And that's pretty common
in the Japan market.
KH MIN: In Korea too.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: So you
should use the staged rolling.
MICHAEL YEUNG: I think
one thing to note
is that beta testing does
not affect your ratings.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--beta testing--
LEON ZHAO: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
beta testing--
--beata testing--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--feature--
OK, so my next
question will be the
how developers should
communicate with the Google
Play team, to Dana maybe.
Some other people's--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Google
Play team--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DANA YANG: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--email address--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--play-dev--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--screen shot--
--email-- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[? package ?] [? name ?]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--screen shot--
procedure
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--developer--
LEON ZHAO: OK.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
OK, yeah, OK, so I'm going
to also ask another question
from the audience.
From Jenny Chan, so if your
app language is in English,
should you still have
localized listing?
So if the app itself is
in English-- the interface
is in English-- but for
example, they launch in Japan,
do they still need to localize
the title and introduction
and all that?
KOH KIM: It depends on what
region you're launching it.
So it's always best to localize.
Even if you localize
your app description,
it's always best
to localize the app
within the application itself.
I mean, it just
shows that you care
about your user in that
market despite what it is.
But obviously that will depend
on which market you're in.
Some markets-- let's
say Japan, Korea, even
some European
markets, like Russia,
and in Brazil-- they
definitely prefer
seeing an application in their
own local language, because not
everyone speaks English
there very well.
But it really just depends
on the market, right?
Like, you're perfectly fine
using English in Singapore
or using English in even some
southeast Asian countries.
But a lot of that depends on
A, the type of application
you have-- a photo taking
or video sharing app
is going to be much
easier to localize
than like a retail
commerce app that's
going to require a
lot of text, right?
So a lot of it depends on the
type of application you have,
which region or market that
you're launching in, and then
also take advantage of some of
the services that Google has.
We offer in-app translation
within the developer console.
You can actually take
your text strings
and request it actually go
to some of the translation
services we offer and be like,
hey, help me translate my app.
We do offer those services.
That kind of does
it right in house,
and it's right from
the Developer Console.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU:
For the Japan market,
if you provide and distribute
the [? know ?] [? damage ?]
required to [? reading ?]
the English,
then probably you can distribute
in English in the application,
but you should change the
titles and the descriptions
in Japanese.
So first off, at the
first look the user
decided whether they
will download or not.
So the first view of the
titles and description
should be translated
into Japanese.
If you think that
your application
is not that much of a
request to the ability
of their English skills.
KH MIN: Pretty much
the same in Korea.
So you need to localize.
And then I have seen
two or three application
which are very interesting.
They are asking
users to localize.
So this--
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: Volunteer?
KH MIN: Yeah, volunteer, so they
asked them to be volunteering
as localization people.
And then it's very
interesting for us
to see that many
people didn't really
want to become a volunteer
for that applications.
So I think you can
consider that option.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KOH KIM: Well that's why--
that's why app design is
very important, right?
Really thinking about
your UX and making sure
that you have the
right call to actions.
I mean the perfect scenario
is you don't need text
to explain what a user needs
to do within your application.
That means you have designed
a very good app if there's
no need for even
language understanding
to understand what to do.
And so, if you can
achieve that then,
really language
shouldn't matter, right?
But we're not there yet.
So there's obviously going
to be some applications where
you do need some localization.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: At
least in top applications,
providing a game tutorial
in applications--
it's not actually the
game, but they are
given the tutorial like a game.
So it tries to force the users
to use their own functions
as a tutorial.
That's one solution for
application developers too.
LEON ZHAO: OK, so my next
question is for Michael
on the [? development ?] team.
So we know one of the unique
features Android platform
is about the
notification, right?
Is there a way to balance
leveraging notification feature
without explaining to the users?
What are your suggestions?
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
MICHAEL YEUNG:
Yeah, notification--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--notification--
--default--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[? Android.developer.com ?]
--setting-- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--notification setting--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--notification--
[? based ?] [? on ?]
[? listings ?]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--beta testing--
--notification--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
LEON ZHAO: OK.
Anything to add on your-- OK.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
So this one is asking what are
some of the non-paid, promotion
services that can be
offered in Google Play,
like, instead of
buying advertising
to promote their apps, what
are some-- by Google Play?
So they can get--
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah, yeah, something like that.
Yeah.
KOH KIM: So, I
think-- [INAUDIBLE]
LEON ZHAO: For non-games, yeah.
KH MIN: So Google Play started
to invest in TV commercials.
So in the US,
Japan, and Korea, we
started to do TV
commercials, which
is out-of-store marketing.
So the application
can be included
in those TV commercials.
I think that is one opportunity
that you can get from Google.
KOH KIM: So ultimately,
it starts out
with you've really got to
build a good application--
good quality
application-- that's
following the core
quality guidelines,
also making sure you
follow our policy,
and then also we talk
a lot about featuring.
And so the first
step is how do you
get an application
that's worthy of being
featured by Play Store in
any of our major markets?
And that's of course
following all the guidelines
to make sure you do that.
And then once you fulfill
that, then there's
all these other
opportunities to be placed.
There's Editor's Choice.
There's also opportunities to
be in many of our curated pages
and collections that
occur throughout the year.
We do a number of
seasonal promotion,
raging from New Year's-- both
the Roman and also the Lunar
New Year promotions,
depending on which market
you're in-- also the holiday
promotions that are obviously
upcoming, and then even on
top, of that, as KH mentioned,
we are now doing a
lot of TV commercials,
a lot of brand marketing
in a number of outlets,
and also we have social media
online marketing channels
in order to expand.
Our platform is only successful
because of the content
that you, as a developer,
are making for us.
And we want to make sure
we highlight the best.
And who knows?
I think we're going
to see there's
a lot of great developer talent
that's out here in this region.
And we'd love to see
someone from here
break out into the market.
[INAUDIBLE]
LEON ZHAO: OK.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
So when the app's
newly released,
how do you get a better
performance, like anything
that they should be aware of?
I think that may be
related to staged rollout.
But any other
suggestions to them
if they want to publish a
game-- sorry, newly published
apps-- that they should be aware
of and suggestions to them?
KOH KIM: User feedback.
User feedback.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: User
feedback and the [? plight ?]
of user feedback and also
if they got a good user
review-- that's a good
start to distribute
their applications on Play.
KOH KIM: And sometimes you don't
need to do beta testing too.
there are some developers at
choose to actually soft launch
in certain markets to be able
to test whether that application
is a right fit.
So for example, I
mean you wouldn't
want to launch your application
in the United States
if you've never done
any testing or have
no idea whether this specific
application is something that's
going to be very,
very attractive
or very engaging with a US user.
So you may try to launch this
app in Canada, or New Zealand,
or Australia, or in an
English-speaking market just
to kind of test the
waters a little bit
and see what the
initial feedback is.
And then that way you can
kind of test against bugs
and also test against
what a typical user
engagement or behavior is going
to be like, which will actually
get you ready to launch much
bigger, say, in the United
States.
KH MIN: I think the user's
point about customer support
is really important.
So you need to
manage user ratings.
So when developers launch
their applications,
there are a lot of
comments after that.
And then I suggest you review
those comments and then reply
for that [? coding need, ?]
so that user
can get some positive
feelings on your services.
And you can get some sense
that the user needs this--
the user needs these
functions-- so you
can improve your applications.
And then the user
rating is one factor
that we use to
identify that this is
a good application for users.
So maybe we can consider that
for our featuring process
too, so--
[INAUDIBLE]
DANA YANG: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
LEON ZHAO: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
OK, that's for a
new game release.
So I got a question
of user engagement.
So how do you increase the user
engagement in particular apps?
Anyone?
Any suggestions?
So after they download
the apps how do they--
MICHAEL YEUNG:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
--content is king.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
user--user engagement--
--content--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--back button--
--Android--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--increase user engagement--
KH MIN: I know an application
which is used car trading.
So you know, I don't search
"new car" every day, right?
So the [? native ?]
of that service
is actually that we expect
that user engagement is
super low, right?
So the app
developers, their idea
is that after analyzing,
OK, so this user likes
some German cars.
And after they
recognize that, they
started to send newsletters
for German cars.
So I think you need
to spend some time
to know more about your users.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: I thought
Koreans only like Korean cars.
And also keep continuing to
maintain and update the date.
So if the user couldn't
get that much update
and no improving
the application,
then the user will leave.
So keep continuing to
maintain the updates,
and fixing the bugs, and
adding the new functions
in the application.
It's super basic, but that's
the way to get user retentions.
KOH KIM: And take advantage
of the notifications
features, as well.
It's a great way to communicate
updates to your users.
Or let's say you have upcoming
promotions or things that you
want to highlight,
notifications are
a great way to kind of
re-engage users as well.
HIROTAKA YOSHITSUGU: And from
the developer perspective
is the upkeep, continuing
the updating is pretty--
given the cost,
have to pay the cost
to develop those applications.
Then we are college
in Japan market--
and also the Korean
market-- we inclined
to chance the subscription
business model,
and that business
model makes it more
easy to invest in updating too.
So that would be more good
feedback from the users,
and then the developer can
give them more updates,
and the user can continue
to get the new functions.
And then if the user keeps
subscribing the contents,
then we probably can
get the monetizations.
So that's a good,
positive spiral.
It's getting to trend in
Japan and Korea market.
LEON ZHAO: OK, so since
we're on business model
and making money, what are some
of the commonly seen business
models for apps that you
have seen in the market
that you work with?
I think subscription
is a good one.
KOH KIM: Yeah, subscription
is actually one big one.
Pandora-- a lot of our music
services-- and media companies
like "New York Times"
employ subscription
as a way to monetize
a lot of their users.
In some cases, you do see
some in-app purchases,
but it's been
largely subscription.
LEON ZHAO: OK, cool.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
AUDIENCE: OK, hello.
I'm from Dolphin Browser,
and I'm the product manager
from Dolphin.
So because our
product is browser,
we have to adapt our product
to many different sized Android
devices.
And this is one of
the biggest challenges
for Android APP is to
adapt to many devices.
So for the new material design,
do we have any improvements,
in terms of when you
design the APP it
can help us better adapt to
different-sized sized devices?
For example, the menu
may be hidden them
for those screen size devices,
or something like that.
Yeah, that's my first question.
And the second question
is, just out of curiosity,
because I've seen Google has
Google+ and the Maps have many
good material design
examples already.
But Chrome browser,
which I think
hasn't been applied the
material design yet-- is there
any specific reason the Chrome
browser hasn't that adopted
that, or something else?
Yeah, just those two questions.
Thank you.
MICHAEL YEUNG: OK.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--material design--
for tablets or phones--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--use fragments [? don't ?]
[? use ?] activities,
because-- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--elements--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--fragment--
--phone book--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--activity--
--tablet--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--fragment--
[? developer.android.com ?]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--break point--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] --break
point [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--layout XML--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--XML--
--Nexus 9--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--Chrome-- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--material design--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--Android--
--web-- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--specific--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--Chrome-- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--material design--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--google.com/design--
--the material design--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--material design--
--Android-- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--JavaScript--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--Chrome developer--
--JavaScript--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--material design--
--Android--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] --Chrome--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
web [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
LEON ZHAO: OK.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--Google Play--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
LEON ZHAO: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
DANA YANG: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Google
Play [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
For, example, I search
on [INAUDIBLE] I
wish [INAUDIBLE] [? Play ?]
was the first app in my search
list.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[INAUDIBLE]
KH MIN: So actually, one
thing I'm going to comment
is actually many
developers, they really
want to be searched
when users search.
So sometimes they are putting
some irrelevant keywords
on their discussions,
which we prohibited.
So actually, we are
working on making
the descriptions as relevant as
possible for the applications.
So that's one thing
we are working on.
And also the algorithm of the
search is getting improved.
So we cannot pin the search and
research for certain keywords.
But we are improving
the search algorithm
so that user can
find the content
that he or she wants to find.
So that's one [INAUDIBLE]
LEON ZHAO: OK.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]